purity program at Hampshire College in
Massachusetts a contributor to the
nation and author of resource Wars next
he presents his arguments that natural
resources will be the source of global
conflicts as about an hour ten minutes
Michael Claire is the director of the
peace and world security program at
Hampshire College and mass it's a real
pleasure to be welcoming Michael Claire
to Wordsworth tonight
ten years ago if you can believe it ten
years ago during the Gulf War there was
much talk about how that conflict was a
harbinger of things to come because of
the advanced technology used during the
Gulf War and the remote nature of the
remote control nature of the conflict
but having read Michael Clare's new book
resource Wars it's clear that that war
may in fact be a harbinger in in many
other more serious ways as a war over
control over limited supplies of our
world's natural resources
Michael's thesis is fascinating it is
extremely well argued and quite concrete
in its presentation
Michael T Clare is the director of the
five College Program in peace and world
security studies in Amherst
Massachusetts and the author of numerous
books on the changing nature of warfare
including low intensity war warfare
world security and rogue states and
nuclear outlaws he has come to us
tonight from Northampton Massachusetts
and we're extremely honored that he
could do so please join me in welcoming
Michael T Claire thanks thanks Brian and
thanks we're it's worth for letting me
come and thank you all good people and
friends for coming this evening I should
mention that this event is also
sponsored by the world affairs council
of Boston and I'm grateful for their
support as well well I'm sure you've all
seen your newspapers and you know that
President Bush chose the state the
official publication date of my book to
announce his new energy plan I'm very
grateful for his good foresight in
choosing this state
and I'm sure that questions will come up
later and I look forward to your
questions about thus the specifics of
the energy plan I downloaded it it's 175
pages
I haven't read every page in the few
hours I've had it but I have a pretty
good idea of what he says so I hope we
could come back to that and I certainly
will allude to it I'm gonna talk about
the main thesis of my new book resource
Wars and I want to tell you a little bit
about how I came to write this book I
started about five years ago and my
intent and writing resource Wars and the
research I did for it was to better
understand the reasons for so much of
the conflict that we've seen in the
1990s now try to remember it wasn't very
long ago that the Cold War ended in 1990
with the fall of the Berlin Wall and we
remember people on top of the Berlin
Wall shaking hands and all of the talk
of a new world order in which conflict
would largely disappear where
governments would cooperate with one
another to solve world problems and we
really felt at the time I certainly did
that the level of violence would go down
with the end of all of that Cold War
antagonism well as you know it didn't
work out that way
the 1990s was a period of intense
violence more conflict even than in
previous decades the level of casualties
has gone up in the 1990s and many of
those conflicts is still under way so
the hope for a rapid drop in the level
of global violence that that hope
disappeared and people tried I think to
understand why that was so why should
conflict go up in this period and
various explanations were given many of
them had to do with ethnicity and we
heard a lot about with the end of the
Cold War with the end of the pressure
imposed by the superpowers on their
allies and clients that ancient hatreds
had boiled
to the surface and we had this kind of
primitive fighting between tribes and
religious groups and clans and that was
the explanation given we also heard a
lot about the clash of civilizations
from a certain Professor down the street
here Samuel Huntington at the JFK School
at Harvard his argument that with the
end of the Cold War the major clashes
would occur between large civilizational
entities usually defined by religion the
Christian world the Muslim world the in
the world the Confucian world that the
main battle zones would be on the edges
on the borders between those great
religious communities well I'm not going
to say that religion and ethnicity
doesn't have something to do with
contemporary conflict it clearly does
but I was dissatisfied with that answer
and I conducted my own research unto why
there would be all of this violence and
the more I studied the matter the more I
came to the conclusion that it was
resource conflict and the wealth that is
generated by resources that was driving
a lot of the fighting yes demagogues and
warlords and would-be leaders like
slobodan milosevic and and others use
ethnicity and religion to arouse public
sentiment to support their own agenda
but very often that agenda has very
little to do with these ethnic
grievances and a lot more to do with the
control or accumulation of wealth and
valuable resources take a look at Sierra
Leone for example there are no ethnic
differences between no serious ethnic
differences between the parties to the
dispute in Sierra Leone or any worth
mentioning political or ideological
disputes what's driving the conflict
there is the effort by the revolutionary
united front the r UF to control the
diamond fields that the Cano diamond
fields with
are the only significant source of
wealth in that region and the ru F has
been protected by Charles Taylor of
Liberia who clearly takes a cut from the
profits a very similar pattern in Angola
a war that has gone on year after year
and again we find that the key figures
in UNITA the rebel group in Angola is
are pocketing hundreds of millions of
dollars from the sale of illicit
diamonds through world markets I could
give other examples what's true of
internal war I think is also true of
international conflict I would argue
that if you look at the the positioning
of forces in the South China Sea and the
Persian Gulf and the Caspian that the
areas where military forces are now
being heavily concentrated that behind
that as a struggle over oil take the
Caspian Sea which is considered to be
after the Persian Gulf the most
promising source of oil for the world if
a Clash of Civilizations was the driving
force you might think that the United
States would line up with Armenia which
is a Christian country but no the United
States has chosen to line up pride
primarily with Muslim States either by
John Turkmenistan and Turkey to try to
monopolize or dominate I should say the
flow of oil from the Caspian to the West
so I could go on and show how many of
these conflicts have a resource
dimension to it and I believe that this
is the driving force in contemporary
conflict now before I continue I'm sure
you're saying to yourself well wasn't
that always true in conflict always have
a resource dimension and that's
absolutely right if you go back to the
earliest recorded written histories the
the the earliest writings from the
ancient Near East those are about
battles in Mesopotamia in between
various groups trying to control the
irrigated river valleys between the two
rivers
so potamia between the tigris and
euphrates and much of the Old Testament
is about fights over the the Jordan
River basin
so clearly there's a long history of
this the entire history of the
colonisation and conquest of the Western
Hemisphere is a story of the pursuit of
resources by the European powers gold
and silver and South America and Mexico
furs and other animal products and
agricultural products in North America
and even the settlement of this ere this
part of the world was driven to a great
extent by the pursuit of land fish furs
and led to fighting between the European
settlers and the indigenous peoples
looking at the 19th century the conquest
of Africa and the Middle East the same
thing is can be shown so it's certainly
true that fighting over resources has
been a constant theme in human history
but I think that that having been said
that we're in a qualitatively different
period today that while there are
similarities between what's happening
now and what happened in the past the
situation today is very very different
and I'd like to take the rest of my
presentation to try to argue why I think
that so to begin with what's happening
is we're seeing an extraordinary
increase Stern a huge increase in the
consumption of everything all of the
materials you could think of are being
consumed that rates unprecedented in
human history
just take oil probably the most
important of these from our point of
view in this country between 1855 when
oil was first discovered in Pennsylvania
and the commercial use of oil began to
1995 a period of 140 years the human
population consumed about 800 billion
barrels of oil which is about a third of
the known
quantity of easily accessible petroleum
the Department of Energy predicts that
in then in the first 20 years of this
century between 2000 and 2020 we're
going to use exactly the same amount of
oil about 800 billion barrels that means
that by 2020 we we will have used up 2/3
of the known supply and if t OE
predictions are right we'll probably
have you know no more than 20 years or
so left of oil because of the high rate
of usage now undoubtedly there'll be new
discoveries between now and then and new
technology will allow us to obtain oil
that's less accessible and the deep
Atlantic and the Arctic Wildlife Refuge
and other very remote locations will add
to that supply yes but nonetheless if we
continue using petroleum at the rate
that we are it's very unlikely that will
will go much beyond the middle of this
century with the kind of easy access to
that material that we have now the same
is true of water and many other key
materials this increase this dramatic
increase in consumption is being driven
by a number of factors first most
obvious is population growth in my
lifetime the world population has grown
from about two and a half billion people
at the beginning of World War two to
about six billion people today and the
predictions are that we'll gain another
2 billion people between now and the
year 2025 will come up to 8 billion
people that's a huge increase if you
think that for most of human history up
until this century there were no more
than a billion people living on the
planet and now we're going to jump in
just a hundred years or 125 years to 8
billion people the demand the sheer
demand the pressure on the Earth's
resource base is obviously going to
increase
enormous ly this is especially bears on
the subject of water which I'll come
back to a bit later population most
directly affects water supply and this
particularly puts focus on the near East
on North Africa and Southwest Asia which
has the highest rates of population
growth with population expect to double
or triple in that area between now and
2050 and which also has the most scarce
supply of water so the likelihood is
that the peoples of those areas are
going to face a very desperate situation
with regard to water some of them are
facing that already and this is a
problem of serious problem because these
people depend on a few large river
systems which are shared the Jordan
River the Nile River the Tigris and
Euphrates so you have increasing
population the water remains the same
and the likelihood of intense
competition over those supplies but
population growth is not the only or
perhaps the most important factor far
more important I believe is the increase
in in wealth per capita around the world
and especially the appearance of a
global middle middle / upper class as
people rise up the ladder of income they
consume exponentially more resources of
all kinds especially energy and in other
materials because we as we move up an
income we acquire resource intensive
items automobiles private automobiles
private homes air conditioners a meat
rich diet appliances computers all of
these things require tremendous amount
of energy metals wood in some cases in
the case of meat a lot of grain which
requires a lot of water so
a rising income produces a great
increase in demand for basic resources
and if there were only a few people
moving up in this way the problem
wouldn't be so great but the fact is
that many people around the world are
rising in income and choosing to consume
more obviously globalization economic
globalization has a lot to do with this
globalization is facilitating the spread
of industrialization to more parts of
the world especially Asia India I mean
East South East and Southeast Asia South
Asia Mexico and Brazil other countries
Turkey are rapidly industrializing with
the and driven by economic globalization
producing a new middle class and one
could see positive benefits in the
emergence of a global middle class many
political scientists argue that this
will facilitate the spread of democracy
the free flow of information and that
would be a good thing so I'm not saying
that the appearance of a middle class is
necessarily a problem but it is a
problem in the following sense and and
and and this is the irony for us however
you may feel about our way of life and
its various problems this is the model
that people emulate around the world as
people in India and China and Thailand
and Taiwan and South Korea acquire a
middle class standard they seek to
duplicate what we have private
automobiles private homes air
conditioners computers SUVs yachts and
when all the people in all of these
areas are doing that at the same time
you have a huge increase in consumption
and this leads to my next point the
world supply of these materials is not
unlimited many of the materials that we
depend on exist in limited quantities I
should say it right off that we're very
blessed on this planet the earth did
provide the human
population with very large supplies of
many things that we need timber and
minerals for industry fresh water and
meat through fish and wildlife timber
we've been very lucky but those things
don't aren't necessarily replenished and
some of them are going to disappear if
we continue to consume them the way that
we are take water youth water is a
renewable substance each year through
evaporation the world supply of water is
renewed but the fact is that only a
certain amount of that is available to
the human population about twelve
thousand cubic kilometers per year and
at this point we're probably using about
half of that for drinking for irrigation
for industry for recreation for sewage
treatment and so on and if population
increases at the rate it is
industrialization urbanization all of
these are driving up the use of water to
the point where by the middle of the of
this century we could be using about
close to a hundred percent of the total
available supply of freshwater actually
that that's in statistical terms
obviously some people in Canada where
there's a lot of water and Siberia will
have all the water that they need but
many parts of the world and the tropical
areas will not have enough water to have
a healthy life as defined by the World
Health Organization so there's going to
be enormous stress and conflict about
water
I mentioned petroleum which could
disappear by the middle of the century
tropical timber the original old woods
mahogany and teak many of those are are
vanishing as we stand here sit here many
species of fish have been so over fished
that they're not likely to survive and I
could give other examples so you have a
clash between rap
the rising consumption and demand and
the risk of scarcities now I don't want
to give the impression that that that
humans are hopeless in the face of this
technology human ingenuity will allow us
to cope with many of the shortages with
science we can hope that in time we
could find a very energy free you
technology to allow us to convert
saltwater into freshwater right now it's
too
energy demanding for that to work
economically but that's an area where we
could hope to see some progress
certainly we hope to have new
technologies for for transportation
developed and and there's some promising
developments in that area and if we
worked hard I think we could use solar
energy and wind power and biomass in
ways that will alleviate some of the
pressure on petroleum but all of this is
going to require a lot of human
cooperation and a lot of investment in
new technology and therefore it brings
us to the crux of the issue
how will the human population address
this dilemma of the clash between rising
demand and limited supply we can go in
either of two directions we could either
go in the direction of cooperation and
collaboration across the world to
develop to invest jointly in new
technologies for resource development of
alternatives and to develop fair and
equitable procedures for distributing
what the earth has for us and to
conserve enough so that future
generations will also have what they
need this would be in my mind the most
desirable approach because I think it
would lead in the direction
of accelerating the introduction of the
new technologies we need and would lead
to a greater sense of community of
global community in that all of us would
have to learn to share what's there I
think that would be the road to peace
and by far the most desirable approach
unfortunately as I see it the way I look
at the world I don't see a lot of
evidence that we're moving in that
direction in the course of the research
on my book a lot of studying of the
military planning of the major powers
and what I see is that more and more
countries around the world are gearing
up to address the resource problem
through the use of military force to use
force to ensure that their country has
what it needs in order to thrive in this
more competitive world even if that
means that other countries are going to
have to do with less
and I think this is going to lead to
what I call resource Wars wars over the
control of valuable sources or the
pipelines
or to gain access to resources that have
been denied and this flows from what you
might call the securitization of
resource competition by securitization I
mean the the argument the belief that
the possession of oil or water or
whatever is a vital national security
interest of the state and therefore
something that could be fought over
legitimately probably it's the United
States that's made that the most
explicit in January 1980 at the time of
the Iranian Revolution President Clinton
declared that the flow President Carter
I'm sorry
declared that the free flow of oil from
the Persian Gulf was in the vital
interests of the United States and then
any effort to impede that flow he said
will be repelled by any means necessary
including military force President
Reagan invoked this the the so called
Carter doctrine to permit US warships to
escort Kuwaiti oil tankers during the
iran-iraq war in the 1980s the so called
reflecting of kwaity ships then
President George Bush Senior invoked the
Carter doctrine to justify the Operation
Desert Storm and the Persian Gulf War in
1991 and President Clinton has invoked
that policy to justify a massive
expansion of the US military presence in
the Gulf I think we're all used to
hearing especially from the Bush
campaign about the decline of American
power and certainly in Europe there's
been a sharp reduction in US forces and
US bases not in the Persian Gulf it's
the other way round since 1990 we've
been building up our capacity they're
stationing warships in the area building
stockpiles so-called pre positioning of
equipment for of for several army
divisions to be flown in overnight and
to take out their tanks and heavy
equipment and go into conflict in a
matter of hours so you have new bases in
Qatar and Kuwait we're gonna build them
in the United Arab Emirates we have use
of air bases in Saudi Arabia and a
permanent military force of about 25,000
it was one of these ships the USS Cole
that was attacked several months ago in
Yemen and this is a reflection of the
fact that from the perspective of the
people who live in this area United
States is a very major military presence
in the region and is associated with
policies that many of them object to
that's not the only region where the
United States is involved or preparing
to be involved militarily and the
Caspian Sea we've been developing
military ties with the countries of the
area Kazakhstan Turkmenistan Georgia
Azerbaijan in the anticipation that US
may someday have to build up the same
sort of capacity
that we have in the Caspian Sea and Plan
Colombia the us plan for counter
insurgency in in the in Colombia is
described as an anti-drug program but I
suspect that a lot of it has to do with
protecting the oil fields and the
pipelines that American companies have
established in Colombia Colombia Snowe
the seventh leading supplier of oil to
the United States and has large reserves
that many people think will become
important and if you read the new Bush
strategy for energy one of the points he
makes over and over again is that the US
should rely more and more on the western
hemisphere for its oil rather than on
the Middle East and that I think means
oil from not only Canada and Mexico but
Colombia and Venezuela and I think that
the the historical evidence will suggest
that that means that a lot of covert and
overt military involvement will follow
but it's not only the United States
other countries are also moving in this
direction Russia which is also greatly
diminished its military capabilities in
what was Eastern Europe and in other
parts of the former Soviet Union is
building up its capacity in the Caspian
Sea region where it hopes to dominate
the oil flow as well and I believe that
the war in Chechnya was largely driven
by Moscow's intention to control the
pipelines right now the only operating
pipelines from the Caspian to the Black
Sea and elsewhere go right through
Grozny Grozny was the pivot of the old
Soviet pipeline system and and thus is
crucial to Russian oil interests in the
region
likewise China has been building up its
capacity in the South China Sea the
South China Sea is believed to be a area
like the Caspian like the Persian Gulf
that sits on top of valuable resources
valuable reserve
herbs of oil and natural gas this has
caused problems with other countries in
that area China has claimed ownership of
all of the islands in the South China
Sea the Spratly chain in the Paracel
chain but those islands are also claimed
by Vietnam Thailand Malaysia Indonesia
Brunei and the Philippines and in fact
there been clashes between the navies of
those countries and China and the United
States is involved because we have a
mutual defense treaty with the
Philippines and we're also obliged under
treaty to protect Japanese oil shipping
through the South China Sea so now you
might have some idea why what was that
spy plane doing it wasn't off of Taiwan
it was over the Paracel Islands way out
in the South China Sea the one that
clashed with the Chinese fighter plane
and what it was doing was tracking
Chinese naval vessels and other military
forces in that area and the expectation
that the US will be clashing with China
in the South China Sea area not only in
Taiwan well I could go on with many
other examples the ones that I write
about but let me just say a little bit
about water before I finish up just as
oil has become securitized in the sense
of being described as a national
security issue the same is true with
respect to water for those countries in
the Middle East that are vitally
dependent on a few major sources of
water the Jordan the Nile the Tigris and
Euphrates for these countries water is
view the access to water is viewed as
absolutely essential for feeding their
population for irrigation for their very
survival
and so they have said that they they
view this as an as a vital national
security interest and the problem here
is that you have a whole lot of
countries that have
historically been enemies of one another
or rivals that depend on the same source
of water Israel in the Kingdom of Jordan
and Syria and Lebanon all depend to some
degree or another along with the
Palestinian population with the water of
the Jordan River and the aquifers and in
that region
likewise Syria Iraq and Turkey all
depend to some degree or another on the
waters of the Tigris and Euphrates and
Egypt Sudan Ethiopia Uganda and several
other countries rely on water of the
Nile River so if they're stuck together
depending on the same source of water
they have a history of not getting along
and they have not been able to agree on
how to divide up the available supply so
all of them faced a situation where if
any of the other countries increase
their allocations of water they risk
being deprived of what they need and
with population rising this becomes
increasingly serious in the years ahead
and so they to say that they are
prepared to go to war if necessary to
prevent an upstream country from
diverting vital waters Egypt to said
it'll go to war with Sudan and Ethiopia
if it cuts off the flow of the Nile
Israel has said it will go to war with
Syria and the other Arab states if they
tried to cut off the Jordan River so we
have this same pattern of the the
approaching resources not as something
that should be shared and used in common
but something that should be that might
have to be fought over finally in in
this pattern there the case of wars that
are not interstate conflicts but
intrastate conflicts and this happens
mainly in very poor countries especially
in Africa and Southeast Asia where there
very few sources of income it main they
were the only source of income for the
and
our country maybe a diamond field a
copper mine a stand of original timber
other other resources of this sort and
that means whoever controls those
resources those sites are able to
extract some wealth and to prosper and
everybody else is going to likely be
inert in poverty so it becomes very
appealing for warlords political
factions elites other you know
contending forces to seize these
resources and to fight to keep them
because only as I say the faction that
controls that particular resource is
likely to remain wealthy and thus in
that situation these factions and
parties have no interest in peace peace
is the last thing they want no it's some
kind of agreement some kind of
compromise in which the wealth of
resources would be shared it's much more
attractive to them to keep on fighting
to control what they can rather than
give that up and that's why it's proven
almost impossible to end the wars in
Sierra Leone Angola and now the Congo
one of the the most destructive and
horrible wars now underway and you you
have five or six countries involved in
addition to the the main Congolese
government but also Rwanda Uganda
Zimbabwe and in each case the military
of various political elites have taken
over a mine here a diamond field there a
forest somewhere else and they're just
not willing to give it up and so I think
you could see how in this environment
where where resources are seen as a
commodity to be fought over or a
national security interest we're not
going to see the kind of progress that I
hope for and so where we're left where
we where where are we today and today
was the day that President Bush released
his new energy plan and
my interpretation of it is that I would
say more for us that's what it's about
more energy for us the American public
whatever it takes if it means destroying
our own environment if it means
plundering other parts of the world as
long as we have all of the energy we
need that's our national policy and and
he talks about energy independence in
there that that's a national security
interest that we should be less
dependent but if you look at the figures
closely you'll see that there's no
possibility of that that - - for the
u.s. to have as much oil as he says we
need which is about 40 million barrels a
day in the year 2020 we now use about 20
we I'm sorry about 25 million barrels
today forget forget the exact numbers a
50% increase over what we're using now
over the next 20 years to have that
there's no way that the United States
will not become more dependent on
foreign sources if we do use all of the
oil that's thought to be in the Arctic
Wildlife Refuge which is about 10
billion barrels of oil that would come
out to be it in in the year 2020 2010
2020 when it would be most available
would constitute about 3% of America's
energy supply oil supply energy and at
the same time the US will be importing
about 2/3 of its oil 66% from foreign
sources that's the that's the
proportional difference and most of that
is going to have to come from the Middle
East from Africa which is now becoming a
major supplier Venezuela Colombia Mexico
and the Caspian and in my mind this is a
recipe for a constant series of wars
over
the flow of oil the Carter doctrine writ
large so it seems to me that if we
continue to go down this road we're
going to find ourselves in a very tense
and and crisis-ridden and often
conflictive future and and it seems to
me that if we're going to avoid that
which i certainly hope we have we can
we're gonna have to adopt a new
philosophy I think that's what it's
going to take a philosophy that the
resources of the earth are there for
everyone and for all generations not
just for us but for all the people on
the planet and not just for this
generation but for future generations
and we have to develop a new ethos of
resource conservation of resource equity
of resource sharing and only when we
begin to think in those terms I think
can we avoid the kind of scenes that you
see on the cover of my book in this case
it's the oil wells in Kuwait being in
flames after the end of the Persian Gulf
war about a billion barrels of oil would
destroy it in those fires and it it
gives you an image of what I'm talking
about that I that I hope we can avoid so
I'll stop with that and I'm hoping at
this point that you ask me some very
pointed sharp questions and and tried to
bring some of this out thank you yes
please
I read your book because it's an
interesting thesis but I haven't been
convinced from what you've said maybe
there's more in the book but I've just
taken a course in international
relations and it turns out that a lot of
scholars think that United States
foreign policy for the since the
spanish-american war has been one
disaster after another because we keep
expanding our responsibilities in the
world and you've just outlined we now
feel responsible for the Middle East for
China whatever there is another approach
and that is what Germany is now doing
until World War two Germany tried to
control resources by war yes it did but
since World War two they are buying
their resources they buy their fuel from
from the Soviet Union from the Middle
East they paid the market price it turns
out that they're doing very well by
paying instead of fighting for it and I
wondered if that isn't what the United
States will eventually have to do in
other words what we sooner or later
become exhausted from trying to control
other people's resources and do what I
suspect unfortunately Pat Buchanan would
probably endorse and that is to stop
trying to be an international power
except for things like missile defense
all defense but obviously we have to
worry about nuclear weapons we have to
worry about a certain amount of national
security but we don't
but resources we can buy so I wonder how
you would respond to the prospect of
becoming more like Germany's foreign
policy yeah I you know I think that's an
extremely interesting question Japan
follows in the same spirit resources but
they do just file it this is true and
they don't really depend on our military
power they can buy the resources even if
we yeah that's the part that's not true
Japan is totally dependent on the United
States to protect its flow of oil 80% of
Japan's oil comes from the Persian Gulf
through the South China Sea and those
American soldiers that are there are not
protecting only the flow of oil to the
United States they're protecting the
flow of oil to Japan and to some degree
to Germany so in a militarily military
sense Germany and Japan are don't have
to use their own forces because to a
very considerable degree they're relying
on us now the question would be why do
we
that why do we assume that role of
protecting the flow of oil to those
other countries the Arabs have to sell
the oil suit to somebody and if we
weren't protecting the oil they would
still have to sell it to the highest
bidder
and Japan and Germany are better with a
highly skilled workforce are better and
a highly productive workforce are better
able to bid for whatever price is
required see that's where you get to
that that's where you get to the really
interesting question which is what kind
of society as America chosen to be and
we've chosen a different kind of society
than Japan and Germany and I think we
could have a very interesting discussion
all night and with other people
participating about that United States
has chosen to have a society based on
cheap energy that makes possible the
interstate highway system
suburbia malls and SUVs you you can't
have those things in Germany and Japan
because they price energy in such a way
to make that virtually impossible but
they provide extraordinary public
transit systems and they encourage
grouping of homes and factories around
public transit and their public policy
is designed to facilitate that so when
the energy crunch comes in the years
ahead they will be much better off than
we are to cope with shortages our
society is one that's based on people
having extremely cheap automobile fuel
and I don't think any politician
democrat or republican could go in front
of the American public and we're not
gonna hear that tonight when the
Democrats respond and say we have to
move more in the direction of Germany
and Japan and our public policy they're
gonna say we will find a way to get your
cheap oil so you could go on living the
way you were and that means as I
understand it that's the essence of the
bush plan more involvement more
interventions and more conflict abroad
but now let me
take a few other hands but I think your
question is a good one
Irene please and then but it leads also
to the put a double question one is the
role of US multinationals so if you go
back to World War two the US
multinationals were quite adamant on
preventing Japan from having an
independent oil policy and developing
its own resources and we have the the
benefit of that today but to talk about
the role of multinationals is to talk
about the conflict over pricing and so
in a way you're presenting a macro
picture which is very important but the
everyday micro picture has to do with
the incredibly savage war over profit
and it would be very useful if either
party but neither party will do this as
you say for other reasons would
entertain this question of why it's
necessary for the US multinationals to
have the degree of profit they have
because while oil is cheap there the
degree of profit that they make is
beyond investigation right it's a taboo
subject but it is a very relevant
dimension to the whole subject because
what I would just say they said when you
say and I think your book is important
for this when you say the u.s. is in the
Caspian and in the Gulf there are two
parts of the u.s. that are there the US
military and the US military and it I
think if you study the history carefully
it's clear that there has always been a
partnership between those parts
sometimes overt sometimes covert
sometimes explicit sometimes tacit and
it goes back you know a long way that
you've had that partnership and and oil
I believe in the US has always been
viewed by those in power and I mean the
people who control the State Department
and the National Security Council as
American oil has always been viewed as
as a major maybe the major prop of
American power economic power and
political power and military power has
rested on our superior control access to
oil that was decisive in
world--well one it was absolutely
decisive in World War two and President
Roosevelt was prepared in 1943 to create
an American national a government oil
company like what British Petroleum was
once the you know the British
government's oil company whatever it's
all anglo-iranian oil company and the
French au lait they all had national oil
companies as a national security policy
and Roosevelt was prepared to format an
American national oil company to exploit
the oil of Saudi Arabia in the Gulf and
he was talked out of it in discussions
with the oil company you know let us do
it we don't want a national company
competing but there was an agreement
that the military would protect their
operations and they would behave in
certain ways to satisfy American
security interests and I think the same
absolutely the same thing is happening
in the Caspian today President Clinton
was directly involved in the
negotiations with either by John and
Turkmenistan and Georgia to get the
pipeline to run that way through Turkey
to the Mediterranean rather than through
the Black Sea directly involved so was
Al Gore it was it was the national
policy of the Clinton administration to
promote that with the oil companies
doing the actual delivery of the oil and
so on
so you know this is not I mean I think
what you say is true it's a
profit-making enterprise but it also has
a governmental aspect to it this
gentleman had a question and then I'll
catch of natural resources is kind of
the overall self preservation of
countries and I mean the feed countries
like a company
the idea is to become larger in every
company every country given the chance
to probably take in the opportunity to
to grow and to just expand within I
think Germany and Japan they don't have
a lot of choice
without a military and after the wars
they really were not dictating their
terms
number two you say the progress has not
been made along the lines of where you
want to see it's going this kind of
implies that there you say that without
really mentioning are there really
comparative efforts internationally to
find alternative fuels to find
alternative energy sources I mean you
wouldn't really bring that up in your
research have you found there there are
and and some of them are deeply
troubling to me Japan in particular is
seeking to become energy independent and
they have spent billions and billions of
dollars to create a plutonium energy
system to reprocess plutonium eventually
and then to and then to consume it as
their primary source of energy so they
don't have to import oil and Japan is
probably now the second largest nuclear
power on the face of the earth although
nobody wants to talk about it because
they've stockpiled so much weapons-grade
plutonium they haven't developed the
technology yet but that's the strategy
so that's not exactly a payoff I hope
that countries would emulate I'm
thinking more of an international effort
oh with international cooperation thank
you
I'm not aware of the kind of cooperation
that I think is necessary being talked
about at this point and that's very
troubling to me and I think that the
bush plan is a step in the in the wrong
direction because it doesn't talk about
going that way but only satisfying our
needs at at whatever whatever it takes
so Brian and then you're next Michael
you've written about another subject
that's related small-arms the types of
weapons which are portable by one or two
people assault rifles guns grenades and
in the kind of scenario that you depict
where there are wars over resources I'm
wondering how you
predict access to weapons may influence
the parties we'll be fighting these wars
whether there will be States non
non-state groups that type of thing I
wanted to give it coming down well the
arms trade is directly related to this
at every level that ever you know from
the big Wars to the small Wars arms
transfers are crucial because they are
one of the instruments the great powers
especially United States used to create
a presence in certain areas to give at
the high end we've just agreed to sell a
huge number of advanced f-16 fighters to
the United Arab Emirates with
capabilities missiles and other
capabilities more advanced than even our
own Air Force has and part of the deal
is that we're going to get use of the
base that we're going to build in the
United Arab Emirates to house those
aircraft right I don't remember the
exact number it's a hundred or 150 it's
a large number we're gonna have to build
they're gonna have to have a new base
we're gonna build the base the base is
gonna have hangars and storage depots
and fuel depots and barracks for use by
American as well as UAE aircraft and
forces so it's a way of getting an
American base without saying we have an
American banks through arm sales so
that's at the high end at the low end
when you look at Sierra Leone Angola the
other examples I was giving there's a
direct correlation between the diamond
trade and the gun trade the diamonds go
to Antwerp to Tel Aviv to other diamond
centers they're converted into cash the
cash is used to buy guns and to fly them
back to sustain the operation and as I
said it's a sort of a self-sustaining
system as long as the guns come in and
you can hire people often children child
soldiers to use the guns they're very
cheap and he you know you give them
these assault rifles they don't need a
lot of training so if you have a warlord
you have kids you give them the guns you
mind the diamonds
and you put aside your share and a bank
account somewhere you have a perfect
system for wealth accumulation that
could go on indefinitely and that's
what's happened in these countries and
why it's so difficult to bring them to
an end peace negotiations are not what
they want you know they want the system
the worst system to continue so I think
we have to find ways of intervening
interceding both in the gun part by
trying to cut off the flow of guns which
we're trying to do through the UN
conference on small arms and also to cut
off the diamond part or the other
resource trade part to cut off the flow
of money thus unless you could do both
the the war system will continue please
well this I find this absolutely
terrifying a real recipe for global
catastrophes I wonder if any military or
political or business figures are
looking ahead to what our situation
might be 25 or 50 years from now and
what what that will be and how to cope
with it there certainly are some very
bright dedicated people who are doing
that at the World Resources Institute
for instance in Washington DC at some of
the conservation organizations hopefully
there's going to be a loud outcry
against the bush plan now I've taken a
quick look at the bush energy plan it
when it was leaked two weeks ago it was
all about supply-side build up more
refineries more reactors more drilling
more everything and the advance
publicity got such negative responds so
much criticism that you could tell in
the last 48 hours it was rewritten
because when I have the text of
President Bush's speech today he begins
on a conservation theme you know an
environmental theme so and that's that's
anticipating the criticism that's going
to come but there and he talks about
some of these alternatives bio the use
of biomass wind power and solar power
but where you see when you look at where
the money is going
go it's a dribble for these alternative
plans and most of it is going to go to
build refineries and coal plants and
pipelines and and so forth so there will
be a little bit of it they'll be you
know some talk of it the technology the
ideas are there they're just not the
priority and we have to make them the
priority but this is an opportunity
these issues have for the first time
been raised to a national policy debate
they never have before
so this is an opportunity for people to
speak up on these issues and and to be
heard and I and and I think the the way
I read the mood is that not everybody is
jumping on board the bush bandwagon here
yes please do you think the the Bush
administration is subjective or willing
enough to respond to this kind of
pressure they've already tried as I say
they've already tried to sabotage some
of that by by adding a green veneer to
their to their proposals so it's gonna
take a little bit more effort you know
to cut through the veneer but I but I I
do think we're gonna hear some some loud
opposition to it I can't believe that
Congress will go ahead with drilling on
the Arctic Wildlife Refuge I just I
don't think that's possible but you know
just to give another example they are
talking about more nuclear energy more
nuclear reactors and they say well
public opinion has shifted and I'm sure
if you took the poll do you think
nuclear energy is a good idea people
might say you know in general and then
you say how about in your County and I
don't think there's a county in the
United States where people are going to
say sure bringing a nuclear reactor here
so wherever they try to put that and and
a big part of that is we have a nuclear
wastes are gonna go there isn't a state
in the Union that's going to welcome a
nuclear storage site so this among other
things will arouse I think public
activism please all right I would the
flyer said 7:00 o'clock so I
disappointed that I came here but I will
stay here and there was some confusion
but I'm here great and I you just
touched on one of the things I was going
to ask about which was the the push in
the United States well they're just
trying to record this yeah
the push for there been there's been
publicity and in corporate media about
reopening you know about moving back in
to nuclear power and you just talked
about it a little I wonder if there were
there were other things you might say
about it
and I also wanted to ask as I was just
sitting sitting here listening to you I
realized that my my instinctive way of
thinking about Resort when I see the
title resource Wars I think about things
like oil nuclear power and then I
realized water is probably one of
emerging as one of the most important
resources and I wonder if you haven't
already talked about that if you talk
about it in your book or or whether you
would talk a little bit about things
that you know are gonna be yes but why
don't I why don't I do that I did talk
some about water but let me give a
concrete example of where I think one of
the battlefields is going to be as I
indicated these river systems are shared
and often the countries that depend on
them the crucial rivers are I have a
history of animosity so if you I have a
background as a historian of art and
architecture and if you go back the
earliest monuments in the the earliest
written human writing of from
Mesopotamia the area of the ancient Near
East and what those ancient texts are
about a war's over water
that's that's what they tell the rise
and fall of the kingdoms of Mesopotamia
fighting for control of the river basins
and the irrigation systems
now those same rivers are in contention
the Tigris and Euphrates originate in
Turkey in Anatolia the part of southern
Anatolia the part where the Kurds live
so to undercut the Kurdish rebellion the
Turks
are building dams on both those rivers
and creating irrigation to make them
attractive to give the Kurds more income
and they fi defuse the rebellion and to
bring other Turks to come into that area
to diminish the Kurdish percentage it's
all part of their strategy of internal
development but Iraq and Syria 100
percent of their water comes from those
two rivers and if turkey as they've
threatened seriously cuts off the flow
of of the Tigris and Euphrates with
these new dams Syrian Iraq that going to
be in very deep trouble and I can't and
Turkey so far has refused to negotiate
you know an equitable sharing system so
I can't believe that that's not going to
become a source of violent conflict
again as it was in the earliest written
human texts the same is true of the
Jordan River if you read Exodus in the
Old Testament that was about the
conquest reconquest of the Jordan River
Valley and the adjoining hills which
have important aquifers by the Israeli
people and first there were other people
living there the Canaanites and others
and they had to be slain first before
the Israelites could settle there
well now the same conflict is repeating
itself in the same place now it's the
Palestinians that are occupying some of
that land but water is one of the
decisive issues of friction one of the
main sources of friction between the
Palestinians and the Israelis because
the Israeli settlers among everything
else get 5 to 10 times more water per
day than the Palestinians who are their
neighbors and in an area where there
isn't a lot of water to begin with and
and the Israeli settlers have swimming
pools and look
sprinklers on their their lawns and you
don't have enough water to bathe that's
gonna make it a very angry person and
there have been severe droughts and in
the Jordan basin in it and I think that
that it is part of the reason by no
means all of the intensity of the anger
that we see in that part of the world a
little bit more about Colombia and the
Plan Colombia that's what you said was
something I hadn't heard before but it's
clearly something that's not being
talked about in very publicly and it's
also clearly something that's becoming
more and more important yeah well but
what I don't think is widely known is
that Colombia's principal legal source
of revenue is oil exports now whether
that exceeds the illicit revenues from
from narcotics I'm not sure but legal
exports oil is their primary source of
wealth and it's the primary source of
wealth for the government and so the
government's capacity to survive and to
do all the things that it has to do to
win over the population require that oil
to flow well the oil Ummah is located in
the interior it's different from some
other countries where the oil is by the
coast through offshore
most of it is in very remote interior
areas in the Northeast and in the
south-central part of the country it's
British Petroleum and the South
Occidental oil and the Northeast these
are the areas where the guerrillas
operate from especially in the Northeast
where the the ELN is the the the
National Liberation Army forces are
located exactly in the oil fields of the
main oil fields and the oil has to go
from by pipeline from the interior to
the coast where where it could be
shipped to the United States and those
pipelines are very vulnerable to
sabotage and indeed that's what the
guerrillas do that is their main way of
fighting the government is to try to
sabotage the pipeline
because that cuts off their revenue so
they're constantly attacking the
pipelines and most of the Colombian Army
is actually devoted to protecting the
pipelines so when we provide all of the
things black box and another aircraft
heavy stuff to the Colombian Army I
think it's with the clear understanding
that a lot of that is going to be used
in these pipeline protection oil field
protection operations because that's
what the Colombian military does when
they go fight the guerillas that's cost
the US but I mean they the drug zones
that's under pressure from the United
States but that doesn't affect them very
much the oil is crucial to them and and
the US government understands that if
the Colombian government collapses that
that our whole strategy will fail so we
have to help the Colombian government in
its efforts to protect the oil and it's
a strategic interests of ours to maybe I
told you important that you you will
kind of know but I think it's very clear
please I got digressing a little too
much but uh well I've seen some alarm
about using nuclear power as a form of
energy and I think we've also discussed
some problems associated with relying
solely on oil for our source of energy
so it's wondering if there's any energy
source that has your endorsement that is
my endorsement for the yeah for reducing
the amount of problems we can foresee
yeah I mean I I believe that we have to
go in the direction of solar energy and
wind power and in biomass and other
means but as I tried to argue I think
it's not where we get the biggest way we
could solve our energy problem is
through conservation I mean we have a
lot of energy the problem is that we
don't have energy we have an enormous
amount of energy we consume one-fourth
of the world's entire energy in this
country it's just an extraordinary
amount we consume more than all of
Africa and Latin America in the Middle
East combined so the problem is not that
we don't have energy
is that we keep wanting more more and
more more give me more and in the past
10 years the the average consumption of
oil by the average American family
through the acquisition big vehicles
skyrocketed that's why we have a problem
today so if we shifted to more
fuel-efficient automobiles and
energy-efficient households we wouldn't
need all the oil that we presently have
so the problem is not how do we get more
it's the problem is how do we use less
in an efficient and prudent way and
that's entirely within our capacity
stimulating event I'm always delighted
to see people note but at this point
please join me in thanking Michael thank
you I certainly hope that if you do have
more questions I guess we'll finish now
ok thanks and I need a glass of will
this talk of water with the lights on
makes me very thirsty so Michael Claire
is the director of the peace and world
security program at Hampshire College in
Massachusetts and the author of resource
Wars it's published by metropolitan
books an imprint of Henry Holden company
for more information visit their website
Henry Holt calm